this is a neanderthal skull neanderthals
are extinct species of humans and we
believe they went extinct about 35 to
40,000 years ago and this is Earth and
we believe Earth to be about 4 and A2
billion years old but my question was
always how do we know these things how
do we figure these things out turns out
one common method is radiometric dating
where we make use of radio isotopes to
figure this out but how does that work
how do you use radioactivity to figure
out how old something is let's find out
carbon 14 is a radio isotope of carbon
so it decays into a more stable isotope
nitrogen 14 now if you take any amount
of carbon 14 you want take any amount
you want let's just take some number
nice nice number 100 G let's say now as
time passes by the atoms will start
decaying and so the the amount of carbon
14 that you have will start reducing
isn't it now it turns out that after
about
5,730 years 50 g of carbon 14 would have
decayed to nitrogen 14 and only 50 g is
is left with you now my question to you
is what do you think will happen if we
wait for another
5,730 years my intution says it should
now go to zero all of the carbon 14
should Decay I mean makes sense right
like in the first phase in the first
5,730 years 50 g got dek now we wait for
the same amount of time another 50 g
would DK so obviously it should go to
zero but turns out that that's not what
happens instead we find that now half of
of half of this amount gets decayed so
from 50 Gams 25 G get decayed and we are
left with another 25 G and the same
thing continues if you wait for another
5,730 years half of this value gets
decayed and so on and so forth that's
how radioactivity proceeds so this means
regardless of whatever amount of carbon
14 you have with you it doesn't matter
what amount you have but if you wait for
5 , 730 years it will reduce to half its
value half of whatever you have right
now and therefore that is called that
number is called halflife it's a number
that tells you how much time you have to
wait for 50% half of the amount of stuff
that you have to dek it could be half of
the mass that you have to Decay it could
be half of the number of atoms that you
currently have to Decay number of moles
whatever it's half of the amount of
stuff how much time you have to wait for
half the amount of stuff to DK let's
take another example if you take uranium
238 turns out that it is a radio isotope
and turns out that whatever hter isotope
you get after the DK also under goes
another radioactive DK and there's a
chain like that but eventually it ends
in lead now that's besides the point
what's important is the half lifee of
uranium 238 happens to be about 4 and a
half billion years now what does that
mean well what it means is that if you
take some amount of uranium 2 38 with
you again it doesn't matter what amount
you take with you right now let's take
some random 68 G you have 68 G of uum
238 with you now if you wait for 4 and
A2 billion years that amount will reduce
to half what happens if you wait another
4 and a half billion years well again
that amount will not vanish now again it
will reduce to half and that'll keep on
happening halflife so each radio isotope
will have its own half life but the big
question is why does radioactivity
proceed like this to gain some insights
into this let's play a game let's put a
100 million people people in a room and
decide to toss a coin every minute now
if you get a tail you're done the game
is over you leave the room but if you
get ahead you stay in the room wait for
another minute and toss the coin again
and you keep on doing this so my
question to you is what's going to
happen after a minute we start the game
we wait for a minute everybody tosses a
coin how many people will be left in the
room after 1 minute well you would say
that tossing a coin is a random event so
there's a 50% chance of getting a heads
or tails if I focus on any one
individual I have no clue whether that
person is going to get a heads or not
heads or tails but since I have 100
million people statistics comes into
play so 50% of this group is going to
get heads and about 50% will get Tails
which means half of them will stay in
the room and other half would have left
so we would have 50 million in the room
isn't it now we continue we wait for one
more minute what do you think is going
to happen do you think now all 50
million would leave the room no you
would say hey the same thing's going to
happen again because again 50% of you
know there's a random chance 50% of them
will get heads 50% of them will get
Tails me again only 50% of this will
stay that is 25 million will stay and
the game will continue like that do you
see a padle between these two I mean
because tossing a coin is about is
almost a random event if I were to focus
on one specific individual that person
might survive the game for another 100
tosses or that person might leave the
room the very next minute I have no clue
I cannot comment on what happens
individually but because we have 100
million of them statistics becomes more
significant I can tell that 50% of this
must keep decaying 50% of them must
leave something very similar is
happening over here if you take a single
atom there's no way to predict what's
going to happen it might DEC the very
next second or it may not dek for
another billion years there's absolutely
no way to talk about that but if you
take billions and trillions and
trillions of atoms together if you take
a lot of them together then statistics
become significant and so in 4 and a
half billion years if half of them Decay
well then in another 4 and a half
billion years again only half of them
must Decay and the same thing must
continue doesn't that make sense think
about this for a while the key over here
is that radioactivity is a random
process and that's why the chances of a
radioactive atom decaying at any given
moment is 50/50 there's a 50% chance of
DK 50% chance it will not DK this is the
reason why the statistics works out and
by the way there is absolutely no way
you can influence those chances there's
nothing you can do that will say U force
it to DEC or will stop it from decaying
all you can do is just sit back and
watch it this also means that the
halflife of a radioactive sample is
fixed for example carbon 14 always has a
half life of 5,730 years period it
doesn't matter how much carbon 14 you
take under what conditions you take it
none of that matters similarly half
lifee of your m238 is always going to be
4 and a half billion years done and
that's awesome because now just by
looking at Half Lives you can comment
about which uh you know which Isotopes
are more radioactive I mean which of
these two do you think is more
radioactive well carbon 14 only takes
about 5,700 years to dek to half the
value but uranium takes about 4 and a
half billion years so you can
immediately see because it has a shorter
half life carbon 14 must be more
radioactive shorter the halflife the
quicker it decays more radioactive
something is there are isotopes which
have half lives in mere seconds anyways
now there's one big difference between
the game that we played and how
radioactivity unfolds in reality what's
that difference well let me just move
this thing to the side so if we go back
to our game that we played and we try to
draw a graph on the y-axis we'll plot
the number of people who are remaining
and on the x-axis we will draw the
number of Half Lives initially we had
100 million people to begin with so 100%
of them were remaining and they stayed
in the room for about a minute then they
tossed a coin and then immediately that
number reduced to half half of it 50%
and then again that stayed in the room
for a minute and then again it
immediately reduced to half and that
kept on going right well the difference
is in actual radioactivity it doesn't
happen like this it's not like the 68 G
will stay 68 G for a 4 and a half
billion years and then instantly reduce
to 34 G like over here instead that
radioactivity is a continuous process
that will be continuously the the amount
of radio the amount of isotope that you
have will continuously Decay this number
will continuously reduce and so the
actual graph that you will get will be
more of a curve that looks like this but
the point is after if you wait for one
half life which could be 5,730 years for
carbon 14 or 4 and a half billion years
for uranium 238 but if you wait for one
half life look the number reduces to 50%
and then if you for the second half life
another half life the number reduces to
50% of that which is 25% and so on and
so forth this now brings us to our
original question how do you figure out
age of things for example how do you
figure out how old Earth is geologists
use what we call ziron crystals I'll
tell you what's so special about these
crystals they absolutely hate lead we
not worry about why that is the case but
that's turns out to be true but let's
say you find a zeron crystal and inside
you'll find some traces of uranium and
and some lead as well and just to keep
take simple numbers I'm just taking 10
Mig and 10 Mig over here okay but then
you question like where did this lead
come from you realize hey a lot of this
uranium is radioactive and so this lead
must have come from the decay of uranium
there's no other way this lead could
have come over here and so this means
you conclude that when this Crystal was
formed a long time ago all of those
atoms of lead must have been uranium to
begin with and then you know because of
the Decay they turned into lead and
that's how you conclude that probably
when the crystal was formed you must
have had about 10 + 10 20 mg of uranium
but wait a second look at what this
means this means that about half the
uranium atoms have decayed and since we
know that the half life of uranium is
always 4 and a half billion years you
say aha about 4 and a half billion years
must have passed since the time that
Crystal was formed now I know this is an
oversimplification but you get the idea
right now to age the entire Earth well
we looked at a lot of such rocks which
we believe to be very old and we found
that almost a lot of the old ones date
back to about 4 and a half billion years
and that's how we concluded that maybe
earth was formed about 4 and A2 billion
years ago okay what about the neand
theal bones we used a very similar
technique but instead of using uranium
because uranium happen you know the DK
happens over a much longer time span we
use carbon dating all living organisms
including you and me have radioactive
carbon 14 inside of us and so by looking
at how much carbon 14 is left again this
is an over simplification but by looking
at that we can estimate how long ago
that person lived this is why I feel
radioactivity is incredibly
cool